get to know your neighbors
decide like do you want this happening
on your block and if you don't
then talk back to these because brett i
have seen these kids crumple
so many times when it's one on one and
i'll tell you another thing which
people don't want to hear but it is my
responsibility as a journalist to report
this
most of these kids that i have talked to
one-on-one
are extremely polite do you want some
water can i get you a donut
how are you this and that it's like and
this is not that
they're like oh i'm gonna put on the
nice little act or the
journalist like they're kids
but you get them together and they are
gonna
get that collective effervescence and
they're gonna get the slogan earring and
it's a horror show but one on one if you
talk to these kids
i don't know just to be friendly to be
nice to whatever you want some roast
beef
or just to say no they crumble
i i agree with you and um you know
lord of the flies was one of the
analogies that kept cropping up
when evergreen happened and it was the
same damn thing which is that this
you know good kids hanging out with the
wrong crowd
turn into bad kids that's what's going
on so somehow
you know i s on the right i see a lot of
demonizing
of the individuals involved in this but
it's not the individual
it's the de-individuation that is so
dangerous and
you know it's not it's not unsolvable
but you do
have to say no and you know you have the
same thing
uh you know you demonize like the proud
boys your patriot prayer
and you know i certainly get it in the
media these are not people that are
are very popular but i've also met a lot
of these guys one-on-one
and they are you know one rinsed my eyes
the other day right and he was a
can i help you is like super gentlemanly
now that's going to be
super unpopular to say but hello all
those people ready to
you know say i'm a proud boy supporter i
just said the same thing about the black
pockets
because we all put on our pants one leg
at a time okay
yes there were bad apples yes when they
get together things can be terrible
but individually they're mostly just
young people
yeah i agree and they're responding to
the the situation they find themselves
in so all right you've said something
unpopular about
um the proud boys containing human
beings
yeah now it's my turn sure so
uh when i first moved to portland i um
there was a one of these announced
rallies by the proud boys and
uh patriot prayer and antifa announced
they were going to have a counter
demonstration and andy noe suggested
that i
go and check it out which i thought was
a good idea so i did
and i spent some time on
the antifa black block side and i spent
some time
on the proud boys patriot prayer so i
just i wanted to see the difference
and the the cultural difference was
spectacular yes i've done
exactly the same thing as you first of
all
antifa demonized me because you know
they could edit it to oh he was over
hanging out with the proud boys when the
fact
is i actually spent more time on the
antifa side where things were much
nastier
and on the proud boys uh patriot
prayer side things were more welcoming
weirdly
um and including there was uh a couple
of
trans people who were absolutely part of
the milieu
you know a surprising number actually
i've noticed that too in the proud boys
a surprising number of trans people
i noticed that the other day i was like
wow that's interesting and they're not
they're not being tolerated for show
they seem to be fully integrated into
the
to the people just people exactly um
but here was the the weird story so i
was standing there observing
the speeches on the uh the proud boys
side
and a guy approaches me i didn't know if
he was proud boys or
uh patriot prayer or something else
and he says are you brett weinstein and
i said yeah
and he introduced himself and
anyway we got to talking and i was
trying to you know he was curious about
my perspective on things and i was
telling him where i was coming from and
all
and he said you know i i wasn't
i wasn't always you know so far to the
right in fact i voted for
obama twice and i looked at him and i
said
you know i only could vote for him once
i was so troubled by what happened in
the first one he
burst into laughter he's like i'm more
liberal than brett weinstein right
so anyway we had this moment where a i
realized something which is he
even saw in himself that there had been
he had been on board
with a much different view of the nation
and had lost confidence in it um and has
now now finds himself
over with the proud boys um
but uh you know there was a a
recognition
that we're sort of all in you know i
haven't moved at all politically i'm
still
very much on the left but there was no
animosity there was no concern
it was just it was very much more
the expectation that we differ in our
perspectives and that it doesn't mean
um we can't talk so anyway
it was a an odd discovery let's put it
that way
that's my exact experience too i i went
to a rally
i don't know if it was the same one it
was last uh not this past
not this month august uh august 2019 and
i did the exact same thing i spent time
on the antifa side i spent time in like
the
keep portland weird side which was
hilarious i talked to some john brown
gun people i spent time with the patriot
prayer and the proud boys and
um the only place that i felt
unsafe was
with a line of uh black bloc
kids that were all sort of really
identically dressed
with uh not with shields but with
umbrellas and one kid had black
uh brass knuckles and he he did that
to me and i was it wasn't that that made
me feel unsafe but we were underneath
the bridge and there were about 600 of
them
screaming at the same time and i was
like okay that's about enough of this
um but otherwise you talk to them again
one-on-one
when they're willing you know they want
to stay masked a lot of the time and i
you know it gives them their you know
their secret superpower
strength to not uh be tender
right yeah yeah to not be human it uh
right
frees them from the normal stuff that
would otherwise
overtake them so this
the problem is that evergreen i saw this
close up
and the fact is it was possible
to reach people individually this is
before masks of course
but you could reach people individually
but what happened
every time was that anybody you reached
was then targeted by the mob and
recaptured
and so it's this de-individuation thing
where anybody who discovers hey maybe
the world isn't what i
was thinking it was yesterday maybe the
people on the other side have a point
right that is um
ephemeral whatever recognition they had
gets punished and they go right back
into behaving
as a as a mob well you called it out
group in group out group
i mean we both know that um when someone
comes to your defense uh they are then
the next
ones that are attacked and that's why
people don't do it you know because
they're afraid
and we both get that like it's not fun
to be
you know the person that's you know
under attack by hundreds or thousands of
people
uh but yeah or i remember um um heather
your your lovely wife saying to me one
time that you know
some people support you a few people
will support you privately
no a few privately publicly a few more
privately
most people sit on a fence and wait to
see which way the wind was
yes and then they're the ones who turn
on you which yeah they turn on you and
and wow really vociferously too it's
like
whoa look at her go
exactly well you know i i have
they they have to live with themselves
that's what i think so i don't know how
they do it but
i don't either i don't either so yeah
but you can't live in fear of uh
the weakest people uh
turning on you in order to solve some
problem of theirs no that would be a sad
place to live
[Music]
you